it's the same wedding the same
celebration amount of our table you read
you a guy you got something brewing up
you this is where I'm sitting so if you
end up in the high teens you know where
to find me
today tomasa hi hello my god
hi I'm Renzo I've achieved to buddy and
I'm in a rock band I Walter and level
storage provision I'm trans email list
for Navi I can smell the toilet from
here that's how well we know the writing
room I'm Eloise I got dumped by Francis
brother the SS man back there Table one
oh this is a great table it's a great
one no it isn't yes not it we didn't
think you'd be coming RSVP no and then
yes an RSVP cards that you barbecue for
two years you break up with the other
tech groupie what's with your future
endeavors are you firing me issues
you know what Francis mother cross-table
19 the people that should have known to
send regrets but not before sending
something nice off the registry was able
to disappear in the middle of the
wedding and no one would even notice the
table of people they don't care about
how are we doing back here
let's go what if you came here for a
different reason
today what if you went away with
something better
hey Judas dog do you have that kind of
day wait the things that comes so easily
to everyone else is same so looses No
yeah lenita i come to you asking for
Megan Anne's hand in listing and the
rest of her body along with that hand
this is not going to happen
so you could just stand awkwardly in
front of another table lovely statue of
you how did I not just get kissed it
happens more often than you think
[Music]
you are Romeo and Juliet and we all wish
you the same happy ending I will give
you $20 and stand up right now all right
what honey
Oh how long have you worked here
[Music]